pas diction jacques il ya une question
rituelle entre nous depuis plusieurs
années jacques vergès vous avez disparu
entre 1970 et 1978
oui il n'avait jamais dit vous étiez on
a dit que vous étiez chez polpot un
copain de fac à vous on a vu que étiez
avec le terroriste carlos
vous allez nous dire ce soir ma vie
privée et ma vie privée c'est la mienne
comme le votre vie privée est la vôtre
je vous demande monsieur demande à
personne ce qu'ils ont fait
la nuit dure des deux dernières nuits du
dernier week-end dans mes 8 ans jacques
bassetto c'est une nuit qui a été
prolongée au rallye on n'y arrivera
jamais un jour peut-être mais je vois
pas trop la moelle et grand mystère que
je rêve d'élucider ce que vous avez fait
pendant ces huit là dit il était avec
des amis il est avec barbie